now here's the thing Jeff Goldblum you
you would think you are so distinctive
looking you know you see you you got a
that is called nobody else and yet so
many men think they look like you as
they're on it I guess a lot of people
come up to me and in fact and say you
own my whole life I've been told I look
exactly like you it's a little bit it's
a wide range but I try to be diplomatic
I always say the same thing well that's
flattering to me says I'm nice I wish I
looked like you a little like you
flattering to me flattering TV this guy
he posted this one there he goes I
really could that guy looks like some
kind of like a 50s heartthrob he's a bit
like a man in glasses hey isn't that a
young picture of Allen Ginsberg is it I
think that's a young Victor validus bird
he's been upset about you for years he
wrote a famous poem called how I'll bet
you two could recite it and go
[Laughter]
weirdly weirdly when we announced that
you were coming on the show Jeff a lady
emailed us and said we're coming the
show and my husband is told all the time
that he looks like you so let's have a
look at him where is Andy where's Andy
now there's Andy should I go over and
sit you know side by side do a side by
side yeah
[Music]
okay picture together okay you look look
towards me there's a camera behind me
and it'll take a big trophy
[Applause]
[Music]
why'd you guys so much
that how Andy's wife is got a look at
you look at upgrade
[Laughter]
brice one of our good friends on the
show Jessica Chastain yeah
she's talked about people thinking she's
you and it's happening very she do look
quite alike here's Jessica there's
there's you that's it's like it is what
Jeff said but it's like really really
really true like it's very flattering to
me like she's she's unbelievable what I
didn't notice I was it was happening
before I never you were fake yes so I
went to school in New York I went to NYU
and just went up to school in New York
as well she went to Julliard and there
were many times I remember this
distinctly either many times first time
it happened I went into a Starbucks and
where people would mistake me for
someone named Jess and so I went into a
Starbucks and I went up to the cashier
and I went to order something he was
like no Jess your your drinks over there
and I was like oh no I haven't ordered
yet and he's like like what are you and
I just remember being kind of like it
was like a little unnerving because he
was so certain that we were the same
person
and then a lot of friends and it like
later in years to come would say oh my
gosh there's this there's this woman
named Jessica Chastain and you guys are
you know you could totally be sisters
and yeah and then what weird is it
happens to you as well Tandy Oh who's
your look-alike Zoe Saldana Anna Faris
amuse picture I mean quite it is you
know it's
and then you can see it it happens men
people to my face come and talk to me
people who I've known like for example
bless her heart Victoria Beckham who
I've met a few times okay
and we're in SoulCycle in LA and we're
talking away and this close Jeff okay
and and she's you know she made a
comment about how it's so great that
you're coming to SoulCycle even though
you're you know pregnant I said oh no I
had the baby actually just a few months
ago thinking on God I obviously look
rubbish and and then after a few more
minutes of chatting I realized that she
thought I was somebody else and I said
um Vick do you think do you think that
I'm Zoe Saldana and she was absolutely
you know it's alright because obviously
Zoe Saldana is absolute rare beauty yeah
and you know it but it up close come on
next you should tell somebody that
you're getting into character like
you're you're like a method actor and
you're working on your British accent
ask them if they think if they think
that you British accent is good I mean
he becomes friendly over the last couple
of years so I'm thinking if ever I'm in
LA and I just don't feel like going into
work the next day I'll just give her a
ring
Vontae recive world 3 insanity
he's all over it
[Music]
you